[Musique]
une fois tueur de l'académie royale vous
attendra devant pour talence une heure
sur l'oeuvre de leurs prix nobel notre
radium et rayonne de l'intérieur
dos reis a freedom to become more useful
la lie en octobre à 15 heures pourquoi
c'est moi qui suis en vie j'étais
tellement meilleur que moi mon frère
père ramène encore une journée que
j'avais pu moindre serait d'une autre
titre personnes vont travailler pour de
l emploi non plus albert einstein marie
curie 7 la meilleure parmi les femmes
il ya aussi parmi les ans
tu as réussi
pu le voir
je toucherai
un peu dangereux non
[Musique]
en associant sa faveur aujourd'hui les
femmes ont de plus en plus soif de
gloire d'honneur kg par an du titre je
ne travaille la mode du radium et la
grande folie d'aujourd'hui et celle des
femmes professeurs mais pas pour demain
je suis heureuse de pouvoir consacré ma
vie à mieux comprendre le monde plus sûr
marie curie
[Musique]